That'll work.
Thank you, sir. Where's that? Slug Jackson.
Oh, you know, slacking Off? Yeah.
Are
You ready?
Kicked out. Uh, there's the lady that's in charge.
Yes. Yes, I'm
Good. You got
your paper turned in there?
I,
How are you? I'm good. How
are you? Good. You got this?
That's the only thing we've got right now. March. Spring.
Okay. Memory,
Trevor, Kevin, he is not, he's now us today.
Oh.
About four or five. This
is how good.
How was your It good. You?
That was fun. Okay. You been fast? Yeah.
Honestly, I can't believe I, I can't,
but like I follow you on your, on Instagram
and I was just like, wow.
I know. I don't believe myself, so Yeah.
Me believe I can run faster. Yeah.
Doesn't matter that we're short. Every year gets slower,
so I'm like it.
Are you still, um, meeting at, um, in the mornings?
At at the, at, yeah.
You're a runner. I'm,
And did your brother Ride with you?
Yes, he paced me. So, I mean, maybe, maybe it was not.
Have you got a bowl yet? Not yet.
I'm doing it in the April one. Okay, good.
I know I haven't like,
I haven't rated them be the poll, but I'm like,
That's all old stuff.
Old stuff. That's the only thing we have so far.
I don't know. It's just you can't sit
You in.
Yeah, I did
5K, k
I'm not doing all
You people like that run like, like,
I don't even know all the six K marathon
and then they go drop.
They just like, just like, they do it to be funny
and I like, love that people
that will run in like cross and I'm like,
That's what do they do?
They'll like, people will run in jeans
or like Crocs just for fun and like, just to be silly.
Are you here? Yeah. Talk about hin,
Like, oh, that's yeah. Yeah.
Expected. I know. I'm Like, so what do you just wrote?
Marathon. I did a half What? A
Half marathon Marathon?
An hour and 35 minutes. That so good. Yeah.
And it was the one, so the start
of the course was a little bit hilly and
It was easy. The last one? Yeah.
Except for there was one incline last,
like stretch was really steep.
I almost felt like it was stretch.
No, it did. And Alex was like, come on.
And I was like, I'm coming. Yeah.
He was
Signed up one year for Oh, I,
but I didn't realize it was a trail.
I got out there, it was January,
it actually home instead a year.
It was like one zero.
I was freezing, but I went in and did it
because I, for money, I get out there
and some army guys showed up
and neighbor were running together.
One, one guy, one of 'em, he took off
and he come back, it snow on ice
And everything.
We had to jump creek and everything.
And that guy got back first.
Well, I got back before a lot of his guys did.
And then, so he went back out to get the rest of 'em
to run back with the, he gets back
and he's got ice cubes on his head, snow on his head,
ice cubes on his ears, like earrings.
I said, what happened? They stick head and in the snow.
What? He said, you know that creek we joke.
He said, my, I slipped
and my head went right in the same, yeah.
That's terrible. That was cold. I know.
I went further than I, but I got lost market. Well, huh?
Was that No? Yeah, that was out by Lake
And that was fun.
Kind. Same because it's so like slippery,
like they purposely like, you know,
pushed down the trail or rain.
So you're going down really steep.
Like there's a slide down one really
sleek, steep part of it.
And then like, you have to wait in line.
So it's not really like a ride.
It's like a little more and then
and times
there's, so yeah, you,
yeah, just do
thank you all in together in the yes.
And everybody that does like the throat, like body slam.
How you doing man?
How you doing man? Y'all doing both good. You the one
Of, How you doing?
You ready? Light class load. What's that?
It's a light class load. Yeah. So far.
You
uh, Jacob?
Jacob? Oh yeah. Okay. He actually ran most
At the beginning, but then we, besides
besides
Jacob, a good.
Yeah, it's great.
Yeah, it's awesome.
You know, uh, I didn't, I didn't run
No.
My sister, yeah, I played, um,
basketball and golf.
Like instrument? No, honestly, uh,
my main school was basketball.
My sister ran across country
and con
so I, what's up?
Well, um, I have,
so I, it's called
about this a little.
Yeah, yeah. Okay. It's called
sort of, it's Missha, that's what it's called.
Cold, which is a common between
the right side is a thicker, put this thing in.
And so when three, yeah, I don't,
massive surgery
when I was, and it's, um,
and then what I did was,
part of that was they took out career when I was four.
Yeah,
I can do,
I, it's a lot of exercise
where it's go out, but it's actually really good.
So it's like everything
I'm, oh yeah.
Well, I mean, I like the first time I used to
when I was, uh,
awesome.
Like this class, I,
yep.
Alright, what's up? You? Anything good
on the man?
Yeah. Why do you say that?
No, we're discussing it probably. Yeah.
Well, it won't be for a little while though.
It'll probably happen March-ish time timeframe,
but they keep it in the family.
My son is expressing the interest in living there,
so we'll see.
Oh, my father-in-law school was
Alright. Good
evening.
What's up David? Good evening
and welcome to the last meeting
of the systematic Theology one class.
If you were in here at the first one, congratulations.
You made it all the way through.
Alright, so, uh, let's do this before we dive in.
Let me pray for us and we'll get started.
Almighty God, we do thank you tonight, even
as we gather in this place, in obedience to your word,
we gather as your people to learn from you.
To learn from your word to, to come to know you better, to
consider and ponder what is good, right and true.
Uh, and not only to think about it, but to believe it
and, um, to fellowship with one another in that truth.
And Lord, we pray that you continue to open our eyes
that we would see
and behold the wonderful things you have made
known in your word.
Thank you for those that have been with us on this journey
for, uh, whether it's just tonight or every meeting,
or just a few along the way.
Thank you Lord, for the, the truth that we get to explore
and to swim in and, uh,
the way you have taught us as we've gone along.
Lord, we love you. We thank you for that.
And it's in Jesus' name we pray. Amen. Amen.
So tonight is really just sort of a recap
and a review of the whole series
of meetings we've had to some extent.
Uh, so what I've labeled this as review
and gospel application, so that's
what we're talking about tonight.
But before we really dive into that, uh, lemme start
with a little housekeeping.
So first off, lemme just say for all
of you guys who've come, uh, one, one time or the whole time
or anywhere between, thank you
for coming and for being a part.
This has been a great class and, uh, we've had a lot
of participation and so just wanna say thanks.
So whether you're a just a church member who's just
attending and not taking it for credit, like some
of the crazy people that are doing it for seminary credit,
uh, you know, you've made this class, uh, what it has been.
And so thank you for being a part of that.
Um, but for those who've been taking the seminary class, uh,
there's been a lot of sweat, blood and tears in that.
And, um, so I just want to commend you guys, thanks
for hanging in there, for working hard on that
and, uh, for contributing to the class overall.
And just a couple of reminders, like
as we have a class like this
and as we work on it at whatever level we're doing,
and whether we just come in
and ponder it throughout the week,
or we're spending hours pouring over books and writing
and all the different, uh, joys that come with assignments.
Um, it, first off, just being involved, it,
it makes a class like this possible.
So I just wanna remind you of that.
Um, also, you know, the way in which
I think we could all probably testify hopefully to the ways
that we personally learn
and grow personally as disciples and followers of Jesus,
whenever we gather together, when we study together
and we reflect on God's word
by the power of the Holy Spirit.
So, uh, just a reminder of some of these truths, you know,
'em, but I wanna remind us anyway, uh,
that these things will encourage our faith, our relationship
with the Lord, our daily walk with God.
And, uh, they help us to obey Jesus
and to follow him better in the world as a disciple
of Christ, as an ambassador
of Jesus Christ into the world, world.
You know, we're not just called to, uh, to believe.
We are called to believe,
but we're not just called to believe.
We're called to actually also take the light
of the gospel out of the world, to represent Christ
to the world around us.
And when we are shaped and formed more
and more deeply day by day, whether it's, uh, just in sort
of ethical areas of sort of our, our walk with the Lord
and our own private devotion,
or in the way in which we represent Christ in the,
in the world around us, um, it's strengthened and deepened
and, uh, God's glorified as we are changed
and transformed the Christ.
So anyway, um, we're,
we're not just single solo individuals we've band together.
Uh, we're called to build the kingdom of God.
We're a part of the kingdom of God.
The kingdom of God is Christ
and work in his people into the world.
And just a reminder that it's not inventing
whenever we, uh, give ourselves to these things.
So again, some
of this is reviewed from the first time we met.
Um, the goal of a class like this is not
that we get bigger heads and bigger fuller brains,
although we want to increase what we know, the knowledge
of God, we want to grow it,
but it's ultimately that we would have bigger
and fuller hearts.
It's that our hearts would be enlarged to know and love God,
and that the truths about God would not only warm
and fire our own heart and soul,
but also, you know, be something that would warm and fire
and stoke the fires of the people around us.
You know, I love the image of the church.
I don't, I didn't come up with this, um,
but the church being like, say a, uh, I mean,
what do you guys use when you're barbecuing?
I use propane, so that doesn't really work.
But if you do charcoal
or even just like logs of wood, you know,
when you have a a pile of fuel that's laying there burning,
if you pull some of it off on its own, it starts
to get cold and go out, right?
But even if it's small
and there's not real hot, you start pulling it all together.
It has a tendency to, to get hotter.
And so that's what, that's why we need each other.
Farmer and I called to just sort of be in isolation,
just believers walking our own journey.
Like, we don't need the church. We don't need other people.
It's like a coal wanting to be left alone.
You know, there is some heat there,
but it might not last long.
And so we need each other
and we need to pursue the knowledge of God,
both in intellectually and spiritually experientially.
So anyway, um, when I think about a class like this, it,
it's just one of the ways that we do that.
So, uh, I think I said early on, the the goal is to be
to just informed,
but transform this affects our, our, our ethical decisions.
It affects the way we share the gospel with people
that you encounter.
Uh, the way that we defend the faith,
whenever we're challenged, it,
it affects the way we make disciples, uh,
and we invest in other people
because ultimately, you know, making disciples of Christ is
just that we're passing it along, right?
It's, uh, the call for us, the, the call to be a Christian,
uh, to be a disciple is that we would come to know Christ
and we come to know the triune God
through the Lord Jesus Christ,
and that we would make him known, um, that we would know him
and grow in the knowledge of him.
And in the same way, that's really all that discipleship is,
is helping other people come to know him
and for them to come to grow in that knowledge as well.
So we we're just like beggars that found bread,
Robert's pointed the way,
but the goal is that we're all knowing we're all
growing and the Lord together.
So whether it's here at church, like
I I, I don't know what all you guys are involved in, uh,
say the ministries that you have,
whether it's just the individual that you interact
with on sort of a daily or weekly basis,
or maybe serve in the children's ministry or your greeter
or whatever, the way you serve, uh, say just in the context
of our church here, the more that, that you
and I grow in the grace
and the knowledge of the Lord Jesus Christ, the more
effectively we're gonna be able to
represent him to other people.
And that's just in the context of our church.
Like, you know, whenever you think back up
and think about, um, the people around you,
whether it's the people you, I mean the, the, the way
that it's said, I don't remember who coined this,
but we, we are disciples in three distinct areas
where we live, work, and play.
Right? It sort of encompasses all of life.
So just think for a second, like, like where you live.
Maybe you live alone, maybe you live with roommates,
maybe you live with a whole very large family.
The gospel and the, and the, and the knowledge of God.
The, the truth of God's word has a lot to say about
where we live and about how we live together as husbands
and wives, as parents
and children, as, uh, roommates, um, as what,
however we relate
and interact with, with the people that we're nearest to.
So we think about where we live.
Also, think about where you work.
You don't, you know, you, you
don't get to choose your family.
You don't always get to choose who you work with.
Um, you know,
but sometimes you feel like
you don't have much of an option.
Does anybody here ever find it? Okay, let me back up.
Do you ever find it challenging
to live in a house with people?
Okay, no lying.
Um, do you ever find if you live alone,
do you ever find that challenging?
No. Okay. That's challenging.
Um, if you, if you ever work
with people like you work in an office, do you ever find
that hard to deal with?
Okay, so where we live work
or we live, work where we play, that's just sort
of a cheap word that means what you do for fun
or when you're not living at home
or you're not, uh, working.
And so just the reality, kind of the idea,
the reason I like those three categories
is represents sort of all of life.
There's different ways you could slice that up,
but that, that when we think about these truths
and when we walk in obedience to the word of God,
we walk in light of the word of God.
It, it should and it does,
and it can affect our whole lives.
And I just want to, that's why I just want
to belabor the point, and maybe some of this is obvious,
but it's that, like, when I'm thinking through how
to create a class like this
and where I was putting together the outline
and all of that, it's that I, I want us to go deep and wide
and to really learn a lot
and to thank God's thoughts after him.
But I also want to be sure we reel in
and we recognize we're not just sort of brains walking
around, but we're, we're whole people.
And the word of God has a lot to say to our whole lives.
And, um, and at the end of the day, you know, in the book
of James, he would say, it's not just that we want
to be hearers of the word, but doers also.
So it's just really important that when we think
great thoughts about God, which we should, we should think
more about the great thoughts about God than we do,
but we ought to labor
and be careful to couple that also with,
in having a major influence on our lives.
So I just wanna invite us into that again.
Um, and as we wrap up this semester, so, um,
at, at the end of the day, what we're really talking about
is there's, there's two things in the Bible
and God's word that are really overarching banners over
everything we believe and do.
It's the great commandment
and the great commission, uh, who can summarize
for me the creator just state
the great commandment when Jesus
said, this is the greatest commandment.
What, what is it? Love the Lord your God
with all your heart, soul.
Okay, yeah. You got it's love.
God love others is the second.
Okay, well, that's the second. Yes. Right? Yeah.
So, and often we kinda lump those together
and I think rightly so.
Um, so,
but Jesus said the greatest man was this, that you love God
with all your heart, soul, mind and strength,
or whatever your English translation says.
Um, and so the point is all of you, right?
And so that you love God, uh, sometimes we say, well,
I I love God with my heart.
What we're trying to do here is love God
with our minds, you know?
And so, but at the end of the day, um, it's not,
it's not just that.
What, what, well, one of the ways that we get to live
that out is with what you said of the second commandment.
Jesus. They weren't, he, they weren't asking him
what the second greatest commandment they were asking about
the first, but he volunteered it
because I think he rightly understands the way we're wired
and the way we are, which is sometimes it's easy to say,
well, the Bible says, um, how can you say I love God,
who I can't see when you hate your neighbor,
who you can see.
And so there's sort of a challenge of practicality.
We have this, uh, vertical relationship to the Lord.
And then a lot of the times, the way
that plays out in the world is
horizontally with the people around us.
And so there's just that challenge
to not only be here is the doers of the work.
So that's the great
commandment to love God with all our heart.
So mind and strength, the great commission is what
The nation Okay.
That's right. Going all the world.
Uh, well, and it begins with,
Christ has all authority, right?
All a authorities given in heaven
and on earth's, really nowhere else.
Okay? That's about it. Right? Heaven and earth.
And then he just said he commissions his people
to go into the world and to make disciples.
And, uh, that's helped him come to know and to come to grow.
What, what's that? So even they know fathers have
to Absolutely.
Yeah, that's right. In the name of the Tri God.
So to evangelize them, to baptize them
and to teach them, to teach them what all
that they've learned, to observe, all that they've learned,
all, all that, who's learned all
that Christ commanded, okay?
All that Christ commanded. Yeah.
So the disciples, what they had learned from him, uh,
that they would teach those things
and teach them to obey them, right?
And so disciple the nations in the knowledge of God.
So anyway, um, I just wanna remind you, as we sort of begin
to land the plane on this, I just want
to emphasize these things again, sort of the practical side
of it, that it's important that we, uh,
we do more than just think about it,
but we be challenged at a heart level to really, uh,
be influenced by in our lives.
Um, so anyway, that was a long way of saying thanks
for being a part of this class.
That's where we are actually.
Hey, uh, I've got slides for this. Look at that. Thanks.
Hey, I'm not dumb. Actually, I wanted the next, I wanted
to say thank you to our elders who've taught the
classes that you guys have taught.
And, uh, thank you
so not, not only for teaching the classes,
but al also just learning alongside us
as students of the word.
And, uh, you guys are a model of
that, and we appreciate that.
And, uh, so we're grateful for that.
Um, and then last but not least, I, I could say a lot more,
but I really wanna say thank you to David Barnes.
Because David Barnes.
Yeah, because
David Barnes is not only a very diligent student.
He has balanced enthusiasm for this, these classes
and, uh, the times whenever I'm dragging or behind,
and he comes in and prods me along.
Really appreciate that. Uh,
David does a ton behind the scenes.
He does a lot of prompt, like he organizes
and manages all the paperwork and,
and some of the logistics of Thank you,
David, for what you do.
Yeah. Uh, okay.
So where are we?
Ah, next.
Okay, so, so next semester, this is just kind of a,
a blurb for next semester.
There will be other classes going on.
Uh, the elders are teaching a class.
Remind me the name of it. It's Bible, uh, acronym.
It is an acronym, but in short, it's a walk
through the Bible, like an intro to the Bible for people
to need a refresher or
For the first time What's in the Bible?
How's the storyline?
Storyline of the Bible? Yeah. So there's that.
There will be, I think a couple of others.
But what we will be doing is, again, five major topics.
Um, Christology, pneumatology, soteriology,
ecclesiology, and eschatology.
And, um, the way I sort of broke it up is there's,
part one is the first three topics,
we'll have a three week break.
Everyone will have a three week break for,
what is it like worship night,
or there's, uh, a prayer meeting to spring break.
There's several things all in a row.
And, um, and then the part two.
So if you kind of needed to break it up
and you want bounce between classes, you can do that.
Uh, not if you're in for credit, that's not an option.
But, um, anyway, just to, so, you know, that's sort
of what's, uh, what's coming.
So, uh, because, you know, there is sort of a rhyme
and a reason to the, the way we've kind
of studied these things as, you know, what we,
what we landed on the, the chapter in our textbook
that we're bended on was the doctrine of sin.
And, um, and you know, if you're paying attention,
you can be tempted to be like, man, I sort of hate
to end there, you know?
But, uh, but good news, there's good news coming, right?
The first thing we're gonna study right out the gate is
the Doctrine of Christ.
And just like in this semester, we spent a ton of time
on the doctrine of God
and the knowledge of, of God, who he is
and what he's like and what he's done.
Um, in the same way we're gonna spend a lot
of time on the doctrine of Christ.
And that'll be sort of the major feature there.
And let's see here.
Alright, so
we've covered, we've covered a lot of ground as we've been
through all of these subjects.
So let, lemme just ask you this it, for
however many classes you've been a part of
or how involved in it you've been, tell me what,
what are some of the, I know I've named a few,
but what are some of the topics
that we've been talking about in this class?
It come to mind for you,
Trinity.
Okay. Trinity Attributes to God.
What's that? Attributes. Okay. God's attributes.
Okay. It's communicable and incommunicable.
The doctrines of man and Christ.
Okay. Of, uh, when you say of Christ,
what, uh, what way in particular have we
looked down? The persons
Of Christ?
Okay. Yeah. Especially, uh, in relation to,
um, the Trinity.
Yeah, that's right. Atonement
At, Yep.
What's that?
C Sim. Yeah, yeah. Right. Okay.
That's right. Yeah. We all, okay.
What was the, do y'all remember the first one?
We studied the first
doctrine. Helen taught on it.
That's why don't remember.
Sorry, Alan. I remember. And only part of it got recorded.
Um, that was when I was running the technology.
Um, so it was the doctrine of the word of God,
and, um, so foundational to, to all the other things.
'cause that's how we know them. We're talking about
revelation, general revelation, the sun of the moon,
the stars, the amoebas.
They, they tell us there's a creator these wise
and infinite and creative.
Um, but the word of God, what we call special revelation, is
what teaches us,
particularly the things we're talking about.
It's like you wouldn't know
something about the incommunicable attributes
of God if he hadn't told us.
Right? And so the word of God is so foundational to that.
So, um, doctrine of man, doctrine of God sin.
Um, so, we'll, we'll do a little more of this
as we roll along, but what are, uh, let me ask you this way,
what about any
or all of that has been something for you
that has either been new
or newly compelling, like something that is either like,
man, I haven't really ever thought about that,
or something that has been sort of eye-opening
for you that you'd be willing to share
If there's anything
I did not really Understand and still don't,
but maybe just a ble pull more of the Holy Spirit,
who he really is and yeah.
And how that all fits together within the three.
And, um, and going through that book
to writing in the Trinity was, was a delight and,
and pretty eyeopening
and changed my whole view of,
well, he's not that weird anymore.
Uh, he is not that mysterious. He is not.
I think it somehow get my arms a little bit.
Yeah. That's great. Yeah, that's a book.
I don't remember if we talked about it in here,
but, um, we talked about that one, the Delighting
and the Trinity, uh, by Michael Reeves.
Um, yeah, if you've never read that
or you feel like the Trinity's kind of weird,
but Dan did a great job teaching on that.
Even the, the math you drew out here is super helpful.
Um, but that book actually, so if you can imagine
a book about the Trinity that's fun to read and,
and enjoyable and, and good
and accessible, I mean, then you can read, you know,
a thousand page volumes on it.
And this is maybe, I don't know, 150, 200 pages,
and it's really, really helpful.
What, 120. Okay. That's great.
So, uh, plug for plug for that book. Yeah.
So The Trinity, right, uh, notoriously challenging subject,
but, um, yeah, exploring it is, um,
is really encouraging I think as we've done.
What else
Did Aaron do? Uh,
doctrine, Providence, or, yes. Yeah, yeah.
That really stuck with me pretty well, that, you know,
I know that he's sovereign and he's, he, he goes before us,
but just the level to which he's involved
and the, the, uh,
Uh, I don't know the, not the influence,
but the, uh, pervasiveness of his involvement,
how much he loves us, uh, as his, as his, you know, uh,
greatest creation, uh, is just so,
Uh, So broad
and so, uh, unbelievably, uh,
just overwhelming to me how, how much he's
involved in every aspect, if, if we,
if we really wanna see it that way.
Uh, sometimes we just kind of get caught up in our lives
and day to day stuff, but,
and then really start looking for that, that,
that problem, you know?
So, yeah. That's
Great. Uh, Aaron
did a good job getting me
to really think about that.
I like that.
No, that's great.
I just was
before creation.
Yeah.
I would give another plug for the, um,
was very impactful for me.
And probably the most impactful part was just the discussion
about, uh, you know, that often people say
that God is loved with the necessity of the Trinity,
and that God is
God one person love could not exist.
Explanation, necessity, that love,
but then the Trinity is an overflow
between, so that is why God.
Yeah. That's great. He has been that way since forever.
Right? Yeah. That's good.
I know the, the phrase that has rung in my head
since I heard Dan say it, uh, was the truth.
I know, but I loved when you said God is everywhere
and God is every win.
And, uh, something, I know that's something I've, uh, tried
to teach at times, but it just kind of hid me and knew
and was so encouraging as the more I thought about,
um, God is every win.
Frankly, I've used it in pastoral conversations.
I've used it, you know, in a, in a number of contexts.
Just that phrase is just
so, what
What The role of man and woman,
Man and woman, yes. The
Role of man and woman.
So, uh, their job was maintaining a garden
and man was, uh, represent, uh, the human research
and, uh, a named the, and
after their told, uh, their still the same,
but got increase, uh, the labor for men
and increase the pain, uh, for women.
Yeah. We see that in the world around us, for sure.
Anything else? How about this, uh, was,
has there been anything that was
uniquely challenging to you?
Like either it was hard, like it's a truth that
maybe, I mean, I know you wouldn't wanna say it this way.
Maybe there's like a truth you've encountered you don't
like, or something that kind of hurts
because you feel a struggle with that.
You know, either it's hard for you to believe it, uh,
or you try to square it with your, your experience.
Anything you'd wanna, that could be real personal.
So I'm not, but if there's anything you'd wanna share,
Mark, I'd say if we're, if we're, if we're gonna be honest
and transparent here, um, for me, I, I'm grateful
that Steve taught on prayer and not me,
because I, I really didn't think there's so many people
who are better at that than I'm, yeah.
And when you start thinking about, you know,
practicing much screech right?
And walking the dog, it's, to me,
I find it easier lots of times to teach on the Trinity,
then teach on prayer.
And I was grateful for you for sharing that
with the rest of us.
And To me, I think that is probably one
of the more impactful ones.
So it's not some, not something that I, I think, um,
hard to believe because I believe it, it's hard
To do. Right.
Alright. Does that make sense? Yeah, for sure.
No, thanks for sharing that. That's great.
Anybody else relate to that? Yeah, sure.
There was some conversation regarding John time
and eternity that was
puzzling an insight towards, okay.
Any way you'd want to elaborate to, well, the god's outside
of pride, Northern eternity concept.
Yeah. Sort of. Yeah.
Well, that's good.
Anything else? Thinking or doing? Living
The, the, the struggle and the back
and forth, uh, tug of war of God's heart
for us, for all of eternity
and our will that he's given us to choose.
And of course, his providence nature of, he's, he's at work
and he's sovereign and he can intervene, he chooses,
but that he loves us so much.
He gives us that, that freedom, uh, that mystery there
of, you know, being chosen, being loved,
and yet the ability to choose to go in another direction,
sin and do wrong.
It's that, that struggle that's, uh, that mystery of God.
And,
Uh, It's, uh, very challenging at times.
Yeah. About the whole picture of
that struggle with mankind.
Yeah. Um, anything else?
We have time.
I think those are the part, when we talked about the
providence of God, we didn't elaborate on this,
but it talked about free will versus, um, election.
And I think I really, I'm struggling to wrap my mind around
that, but it was, it was a,
How those two intersect, How they can live.
Yeah. Right. Yeah.
I think early on, um,
we talked about there's mystery in the Bible
and, uh, not contradiction,
but two, two things that are, it's not
that two opposing things can be true at the same time.
Like, I can't be walking with the dog when I'm not, but,
but it is true that, um,
one thing can be true about God here.
And another thing true, I got here,
and I don't quite know how to put that together.
Like, I like the analogy of walking down a road
where you have two sides of the road
and in the distance they meet.
And that's a bad analogy because they actually don't meet.
But, but I like the visual is, uh,
there's a place in which it's gonna make sense at the end.
There's a better analogy
somewhere, but I'm not thinking of it.
But, um, yeah, I think that's, that's a good point.
And I think it's important, even,
and we've talked about this, that some of those points of,
uh, conflict in our thinking
or in, in our trying to understand whether it's time
or, uh, providence
or whatever it is, it's, I think a actually part
of our sanctification, that there are things in the word
of God that are challenging.
You know, like I, in the beginning, I think, uh, the first,
the first time we met, we read from,
it was second Peter three, where he says, you know, um, the,
that there's people in the world who would take, like,
they take the words of Paul
and they just, like, they do all the other scriptures,
they twist it to their own destruction
and cause them ignorant and unstable people.
And, and so the, the recognition there that I love is
that there are things in the
Bible that are hard to understand.
He even says that, but the encouragement is that, uh,
we shouldn't be daunted by that.
And in fact, there's a warning what not to do, which is
what we shouldn't do is we shouldn't twist it.
Okay, well, I don't understand,
so I'm gonna make it say something else.
But that's a warning. Like, that's ignorant
and unstable, don't do that.
But the thing we do is we say, I want to believe God,
and so Lord, help me and might say, Lord, help my unbelief,
or, or help me understand where it's not crystal clear yet.
And, um, you know, I, I mean, you probably all experienced,
I certainly have things
that I feel like I don't understand here,
but then through life,
and that's why you keep reading the Bible, right?
You encounter a problem in the Bible here,
and then, you know, 500 pages later you figure
it out over here.
And, uh, or it's kinda like the idea
of the New Testament explains
what the Old Testament contains, what, you know,
you keep reading and God will explain at some point.
And sometimes it just takes Christian maturity
and the grace of God and the,
and the light of the spirit to see that over time.
And then, and to recognize that there, there may not,
that may not happen with a certain thing in life,
but to also say, Hey, God, is God,
let God be true in every man a liar.
You know, like when God has spoken on a thing,
I may not have perfect knowledge of that, but,
but I'm gonna choose
to say I believe this even if I don't fully understand it,
even if I don't like it.
I mean, like, culturally, right?
There's things in the Bible that are not popular
to say out loud, right?
Like, it's not popular to say a lot
of things that the Bible says.
And so the choice that we have is,
are we gonna shy away from most things?
Uh, obviously you don't have to be mean about it,
but I don't frankly know many people who are.
And so the temptation for us though, is to not, is
to back away from things that,
that the culture doesn't like, as opposed to going, well,
hey, a good and gracious
and loving God has said these things
and I want to believe them,
and I want to be influenced by them.
And I want to align my thinking with them like Romans 12,
to have my, to be renewed in the spirit of my mind.
And just because I don't understand it
or I don't see it, you know, that it doesn't mean
that I define reality, right?
We're studying we're creatures,
and God is the creator anyway.
I think, um, at the end of the day, it's kind of an issue
of our sanctification.
Do we believe, do we trust him?
Do we trust that God is faithful, that his word is true,
and, uh, we're gonna believe it even
when we don't fully get it?
And we'll grow in grace over time.
And, uh, for me, that's the challenge that I feel.
Um, anything else anybody wants to
include or add or
You mentioned you asked the, the greatest commandment
and the fact that it is the greatest commandment
and it involves love
and scripture tells us the greatest issues
of life are matters of the heart, right?
So having that freedom to choose
how better can you define true love?
Because if it's forced, if it's controlled, how can
that be the love that God wants?
Yeah. Especially since it made it,
he made it the greatest commandment Yeah.
To come from us. Sure.
So yeah, it makes it make a little bit more sense than as,
as mysterious it as it can be.
Yeah. It it definitely has some reason
there. Yeah. Some logic
There. That's
good. Yeah, no, that's good.
And we think about God, sometimes we think,
well, that doesn't feel real loving.
I don't know if you ever had children,
your kids always feel like everything you do is loving,
you know, sometimes they're right, right?
You're not real loving. But other times,
you're, you're right.
And they're wrong. And what you're doing
and what you're telling them is,
is loving is the most loving thing you can say.
So yeah. So at the end of the day, we're what we're still,
what the major feature of
what we've talked about in this semester is the doctrine
of God, the, the idea that, so we talked about theology,
sort of the definition of that word is a combination of, uh,
of God and study or a study, the doctrine of God.
Uh, it's who God is, what he's like,
and what he has done, what he's going to do.
And the way that we know that is what he said in his work.
I like the illustration of when we're trying
to dig deep in the knowledge of God,
and especially when you feel like your, your sort
of mind's being stretched and, and,
and you're thinking new thoughts about God and,
and making progress in that.
It, it's, I like the image of it.
Say if you're standing at the, at the ocean on a, on a beach
or the ocean, uh, sorry, I thought that was empty.
And, and you've got a cup. I'll just have a fake one here.
And you scoop up a cup of water out of the ocean,
like the illustration being sort of, God is like the ocean.
And where our brains are, like this cup, you know, scoop it
and and it's like, man, you know, you've got this cup full.
Your cup is full actually, but it, it's inexhaustible.
I mean, functionally, obviously the ocean is limited,
but the analogy is, it is limitless.
It's, but so the knowledge of God is so vast and awesome
and endless and limitless, that
we can continually fill the cup
of our hearts and our minds
and never exhaust the knowledge of God.
And I just want to encourage you,
don't be discouraged by that.
'cause you can't read to the end.
We will spend all eternity filling our cups.
I mean, I think, like, I love the analogy we'll
get into this next semester.
I love the analogy. I think, uh, Jonathan Edwards, truth
of the, what do you call it?
The, uh, you know, uh, it's the ever increase
of joy in God.
It's this idea that we have a capacity right now
in our broken, simple being sanctified
and redeemed state to enjoy the knowledge of God
and to be affected by it.
And, and as we are getting, uh,
growing in the knowledge we've got now
as we're being sanctified in Christ throughout our lives,
that cap, that capacity, does expand over time.
But I think it's, in Edwards, he was sort
of drawing this picture of, of the ever increasing ability
that we'll have in our resurrected bodies
to absorb and to consider and understand
and explore infinitely unfolding
more and more of the knowledge of God.
And it never reaching an end,
because our cup has always, the cup may be enlarging,
but the ocean is limitless.
I don't know if I did a good job on that,
but I love the analogy of, uh, of our cup filling our cup
with the fullness of the ocean still out there.
So we swim in it, and, uh, and it's awesome.
Here's a, uh, job.
26 14 is our memory verse, uh, only the first part of it.
Uh, you can memorize the whole thing,
but I just put the first part on here.
It says, behold, these are, but the outskirts of his ways,
and how small a whisper do we hear of him,
but the thunder of his power, who can understand?
And, uh, I love, Joe has a couple of verses like this where,
you know, you see Joe, obviously, I, how many
of you guys don't even want to read Joe?
You, you're like, Hey,
the thing I really wanna do today is study the book of joke.
And, and to which I would say we, you know,
don't be afraid of the book of joke.
I, I think if you feel that way,
maybe sometimes we think if I read
it, it's gonna happen to me.
Okay? So don't be deceived.
That's not what happens. Um,
what actually happens is there's sort of, I mean,
we could talk about job all day long,
but um, in the Book of Job, we see man,
even in his deepest misery, encountering the
absolute glory and power of God and the wisdom of God.
And, uh, so even in the midst of human suffering,
God's a work in a way to reveal himself to
where we read things like this.
Just a reminder of, uh, the outskirts of his way.
It's just the cup from the ocean
and, um, the thunder of his power.
Like you think about the word thunder.
I mean, I know we're in Oklahoma,
there's a basketball team here.
But, um, so the thunder is not even the thing, right?
The thunder is the result of the thing, right?
The thing is the lightning, the, the force and the energy.
And so just the thunder of his power, who can understand it?
And so job is in awe, right?
And, um, so, and if you,
and if you like job, either a lot like job
or a little like job are either currently suffering, uh,
or you go into a season of suffering, the reminder
of a book like this is that God is still faithful.
God is still awesome, and there's going to be a day in which
that's not your experience anymore.
But what will be your experience at the end is the glory
of God forever and all your problem solved in the end.
It's just that it feels long right now. But that's all.
'cause we have special revelation from God,
where God has spoken, and we can look at his word
and we can say, these things are true.
We believe them. I'm gonna trust in them,
and I'm gonna obey, and I'm gonna trust,
like, what's the old song?
Trust and obey. Why no other way? There's no other way.
Jesus. That's it. I have to trust and obeying.
I wanna sing it. You want somebody wanna lead us
When we walk with the Lord.
I'm not.
Hes on our way.
While we do His goodwill.
He abes with us, him and with all will trust
and trust
and don't beg for, there's no other way
to be happy in Jesus, but to trust
and don't make.
Thank you, man. That's awesome.
Steve, I think we're gonna,
so were you gonna sing or were we gonna
Say? No, no, I wasn't gonna
sing at all.
I think that, uh, one of the things that occurred to me
during this semester, uh, is
that when you said it a minute ago,
you said you shouldn't be afraid
to read the book a joke, but I think you should.
I learned and reinforce the fact
that you shouldn't be afraid to study theology.
Yeah. And you know, you say, well, I went
to a systematic theology class this semester.
I said, why did you do that?
And then you have something else that you could do.
Well, I'm being sarcastic there,
but I'm simply saying that by looking at these doctrines,
by listening to my brothers who were teaching
and, and things like that,
Uh, I don't, some things I knew and read about
and studied and prayed about others I didn't.
But I learned a lot, continue to learn a lot.
Uh, and also it gives me comfort to know that
these doctrines have been studied wrangled with,
argued about people have had different thoughts about
those with centuries.
Yeah. But we all have their freedom to read about them,
to study them, to read God's word,
and then we form our own thoughts with the help
of the Holy Spirit as to
what those really mean in our lives.
Then we have discussions about those, those help us.
So that continues, I guess my word
or my thought to be is don't be afraid to study theology.
There's some big words here. There's no question about that.
Uh, but, and,
and at the end of the semester,
we're not gonna say, well, we've done that.
We're gonna check the box.
We don't have to have good about it.
Again, it's kinda like reading the Bible
through once a year.
Well, I've done it once, I have to do it again.
Absolutely not. Uh, I've learned that.
And so you just keep going and, uh, that's good.
So I just think it's, I appreciate the folks that are here
because, uh, you weren't afraid to want to do this.
And there's a good number of folks here,
but there's a large number of folks that weren't here.
And so we want to encourage them. I think, Hey, cut.
It'll be okay. You, you, you have to be able
to think about and look at that.
I, I don't accept everything Wayne Gruder wrote in his,
in his books, but I don't have to, right?
Yeah. But, but, but God's word is
There. Absolutely. Yeah.
No, it's good.
Anything else? I love this quote in
John Calvin's, um, institutes of the Christian religion.
He says, in knowing God, each of us
also comes to know himself.
And so in Calvin, whatever you think of him, he, he has,
I think, a lot of insight on this idea of struggle
between knowing God and knowing himself,
and that we only know ourselves in light of God.
Because if we're creatures
and if we, if this is what we believe,
which obviously we've been studying,
and we would say that's it.
We're creatures of a creator.
And more than that, we are made in his image and likeness.
And so we almost can't even understand humanity of,
apart from understanding the nature of God himself.
Uh, in fact.
So when, when we realize we're creatures under his rule
and reign under his care and direction, under his precepts
and protection, um, these are all things that are,
they're sort of like light and gravity.
I think it was CS Lewis who said, I, I, he's,
it's kind of a different topic.
He said, I don't believe in God because I see him,
but because I see everything else in light
of him, sort of like the sun.
You can't look at the sun.
I mean, now we have telescopes that'll do this,
but you can't look at the sun
and study it with your naked eye.
But you certainly can see everything else
because of the sun and in light of it.
And so, like, we're like the gravity, you know, like you go
to the moon, or I guess the moon, there's some gravity.
You go into outer space, there's no gravity,
so you just float around.
But, and so in our culture right now, uh,
we are attempting culturally to completely
unmoor ourselves from the knowledge of God.
And so what that turns into is darkness.
And the lack of gravity, right there is,
so we're just floating around.
We don't know what's up or down. We're in the dark.
We're just grasping. And so when we think about
the way this plays out in our, in the world, whether it's,
you know, the sort of the white lies
that we tell each other, or the major lies
that the world's telling right now, all the ways that,
the point of suggesting that, that ontologically like, like
by nature, that a boy could be a girl
or a man trapped in a woman's body, or that
because of that we're gonna go mutilate perfectly healthy
human bodies, uh,
because of this, uh, what I would call not just etiology,
but idolatry.
Uh, it's, it's because there's no light
and it's because there's no gravity.
So there's no, how do you know which weighs up or down?
How do you know what, what's in front
of you if you're in the dark?
And so, without the light of God's word, anything becomes
possible until reality sets in.
And that's the, the, the danger
of believing things that aren't true.
And, and what's so important about believing things
that are true and about laboring to know
and believe the things that are true.
And so I think there's a lot of practical application, um,
whenever we talk about the knowledge of God.
So theology and the knowledge of God, I wrote in my notes,
have very relevant and practical implications in our lives.
And, um, so let it be light and gravity to you.
Um, the, the sim as you know, you've been here,
the seminary students, uh, they, one
of the assignments is they get to take a few minutes
and guide us through a bit more discussion.
And so Jessica Doby, I'm gonna turn it over to you for,
uh, for that.
And then I'll come up afterwards
and we'll sing one more song.
Hello, I'm Jessica Doby.
Hello. Hopefully you can hear me better now. Yes.
Um, I'm Jessica Doby.
I'm one of the ministry apprentices here.
Um, I focus on the international students.
So if you wanna host an international student
for Christmas, you let me know.
Um, the handout
that you got on the table hopefully has a few questions
that I'm gonna go over.
It's the sheet that has the four questions, um,
with a little bit of a change.
'cause Mark covered one of the questions,
which is amazing and great.
So I'm gonna change your last question.
Um, so with the last question, we're gonna change it
to which of the topics covered this semester do you plan
to learn more about?
But otherwise, just go over those few questions
with the neighbors around you.
I personally love input from others that's not sarcastic,
so I would love for you all to do the same.
Just get to know your neighbor. 'cause you may not
see them next semester.
And so, um, just go over these four questions
for about eight minutes or so,
and then we'll come back together
and we'll share about what we have learned.
Um, yeah, that's it.
Thank you.
So I got the clock. I'll let you know
Name's, uh,
I missed the last one.
Spin it around
Glenda or Belinda?
Glenda. Glenda.
Well,
question I
is a good word.
Pleasure and pain that drives every
lot of psychological
from physical.
God. Scripture tells us
there's no limits.
No s
So what she was saying,
so in a sense, in the words that I,
I want to try to summarize here.
No, no. The idea, I'm, what I'm trying to say is
what I hear you saying to me in simple terms.
Maybe that's the way I should say is
that it's almost like we should have a filter
that God sees us as that we should see others as a filter.
One other words, you see sexuality, you see her
as a year potential child creation of God.
So it's, it's like the word gives us almost
like a different kind of filter.
Like, we'll see Marcus talking about we have lenses,
we can see the sun, we can right out the sun and study.
So the scripture gives us that filter to, to see, see,
you know, and, and see the good
because, you know, Philippians four, eight talks to us about
how we really should live.
You know, what's, what's, what's, what's pure,
what's true, right?
But we don't always hear that.
They're not always gonna share.
We're gonna hold up long as they can.
And I got your words foundation. That's what I asked.
That's, that's, it's
dependable, doesn't change, right?
It's, that's pretty hard
foundation, how we should see through the darkness.
We, on the next question, that's pretty, pretty basic things
God does.
Yeah. That's what I have. Trust.
And then I think trust independence.
I know, but what does it say?
They just say him. I dunno.
Scripture say him.
Oh, well it may say him. Does it say the father?
Does it say father? I dunno.
Aaron, does Aaron,
or maybe you guys know, you know, the video that we played
before every service it says we're desperately dependent on,
is it him, him, God, father, father, son, Christ.
Well then what are the elements better?
Now I'm gonna ask you Aaron. Aaron will though. Aaron will.
Okay. I put
Some pressure on Aaron,
On Jesus is
sorry to interrupt.
Yes. Yes. Trust in the benefit. Okay. Christ.
You know, something else too that I see here, number two
is we can be so
Pumped up in Ourself that we
Don't need hear His word.
On the Lord. On the Lord. Okay. Thank you. Wow. Well done.
Where'd your find that? Okay.
Sorry, I cut off in the conversations,
but I would love to hear what everyone had
to say about these questions.
Um, so if anyone had something that they personally shared
or someone in their group that they were talking
with shared, um, feel free to speak up on that.
Um, I'll start with the first question.
How should recognizing scripture God's word, um,
as our ultimate authority shape the way that we respond
to cultural or personal beliefs that conflict
with biblical teaching?
Is there anything that anyone thought on that?
I think it's important enough. It's not just our,
it's the, it doesn't justify to the people
who believe it applies to everyone.
The word, which was one
of the first things we studied in this class, the word
becomes our lens
or our filters marked reference to
how we can see the sun through a filter.
That word becomes our filter
and how we see the, the, the truth, the the,
the essence of who God is, his character,
and how that should influence and guide our lives.
But that word is that filter
and how we can in some way
grasp God in his eternal nature, his omni nature,
how we can grasp that through
that word, that lens, that filter.
Um, our discussion about that included,
depending on your personality type, maybe, uh, there's some
of us who, you know, love to hear something new
and different and maybe it kind of sounds cool or exciting.
Uh, Paul might call that, you know,
tingling the ears or it ears.
But then other personality types really resist anything
that's new or unfamiliar or different, uh,
or there'll be challenging, uh, to their preconceived idea.
Both of those could be like, uh, ditches on either side
of the, the path.
And so what the scripture provides is a way
of taking every thought captive, the ones
that I already hold onto, and the ones that come to me
that I haven't thought of before,
but either, either way,
God's ultimate authority in his word is, is that lens
and that, that measuring to figure out
what is real and what is true.
Second question was, if God is knowable
but not fully comprehensible,
how does this affect your posture
and daily dependence on him?
This kind of relates to the scripture memory
first from today as well.
And Joe,
What Mark talked about in the, the cup in the ocean, you
remember never going to fully comprehend everything.
Totally heaven the Lord,
but, uh, we still want to
know, be upon as much as we can.
Here.
We best really depend on God, even
for knowledge, everything.
Read a scripture like 10 times
and then it like goes off.
And that document
Knowledge.
Third question was from the topics that we,
we have covered this semester, how will you apply
what we have learned to your life?
So that was number four, Whichever number
we changed, the last one.
So just the question that asks, from the topics
that we have covered this semester, how will you apply
what you have learned to your life?
So probably number three, now four on your paper. Yeah,
That's good.
Um, this scripture of Joe just really just cuts
through the reverence, the awe,
the, the overall.
I, like we said, a limitless nature of God
and how that is so humbling in how we
should commune with him and with others.
Uh, in sharing, you know, the, the, the, your sin, the, the,
the gospel, the, uh, you know, the, the great commission.
Just that whole essence of who he is, how
that should drive us, and, uh, be so humbling and,
and motivational to us in,
In What's really reflected in that scripture and joke.
So powerful.
I'm in a camp that, uh, books
probably don't change your life,
but paragraphs change your life
or even sentences change your life.
And, and, uh, the everywhere
and every win, I have to agree with Mark.
Um, that one's gonna stick with me for a long time
because it, it, it tells me one thing.
I knew one thing I had no clue about
that he's got time completely covered,
just like Isaiah four, six.
Then the last question, which I switched up on you all,
um, was, which of the topics covered this semester?
Do you plan to learn more about
the best answer?
Was there any specific one? If you could choose,
Go back to Aaron.
Uh, teaching Providence, just looking for
how God is at work in and around your life and,
and around your church and community and so on.
Looking for where he's at work
and being part of that, the general revelation of nature
and how he inspires us day by day, moment by moment
and through people, his creation, so on and so forth.
For me, it was, uh, just studying eternity and,
and not trying to understand that love between them all
and how that reflects and,
and that I should reflect in my life if anyone, my wife
or friends or whoever.
But then getting to write the paper on, uh,
made it the image of God
and that just became so overwhelming.
There's no way to, you know, it's how all
that relates and the whole Bible.
And then just, except back to that ocean analogy,
it's just overwhelming and how that all relates together
and how he created us to love others
because he loves his son.
I'll hand It back to, thank you. Thank you.
Alright, so, um, like we've done all along,
let's start archeology into doxology.
You stand with me and, uh, let's sing.
This is a song you may know. Must play it this way.
Oh,
Oh, lemme say this.
This is what say
before we say, um, I don't want
to take to assume we don't have time to go here,
but, um, the thing that makes all this relevant
and matter and possible is that just like we've seen,
there's revelation from God.
We understand God, we understand ourselves,
we know we're separated from God.
The only reason that we not only can draw near to God,
and the only reason that we want to draw near to God is
because Christ has come into this world
to save people like us.
And so that'll be the first thing we dive into when we come
back in January.
But we want to sing about it here,
the, the nature of the gospel.
And Almighty God, we do say hallelujah.
Lord, we thank you for just even this song that
Get the best holiday deals at now.
You can get.
Congratulations, Lord.
We do thank you for your goodness towards us in Christ.
And we have, we,
we've run from you in our simple nature, separated from you
and yet fully redeemed in Christ,
fully made whole and new and righteous in Christ.
Looking forward to only a future of joy in Christ
and glory for eternity.
The knowledge of God that we, we fill our cups with.
Now, Lord, we know that our, we will just continue
to drink from the well of living water.
That is your truth. That is who you are.
And we thank you that you invite us to this time,
this semester, the break we're about to have.
I pray that you'll seal these things in our hearts
and help us to continually grow in the grace
and the knowledge of Jesus.
And it's in Christ name. Amen. Pray and
Thank you.
Great.
You Too, mark. Mark. Appreciate you leaving. Hello?
Yeah.